[Música]
un día en 1965 cuando manejaba hacia
acapulco de vacaciones con su familia el
periodista colombiano gabriel garcía
márquez abruptamente dio media vuelta
con su coche pidió a su mujer que
cuidara las finanzas de la familia los
próximos meses y volvió a casa
el comienzo de un nuevo libro vino a él
súbitamente
muchos años después frente al pelotón de
fusilamiento el coronel aureliano
buendía había de recordar aquella tarde
remota en que su padre lo llevó a
conocer el hielo
en los 18 meses siguientes aquellas
palabras que hicieron florecer 100 años
de soledad una novela que llevaría a la
literatura latinoamericana a la
vanguardia del imaginario popular y que
le valdría a garcía márquez el premio
nobel de literatura de 1982
quien se está novela tan extraordinaria
la novela cuenta las fortunas e
infortunios de siete generaciones de la
familia buendía con su prosa elaborada y
detallista su gran variedad de
personajes
y su narrativa
enmarañada 100 años de soledad no es un
libro fácil de leer pero es muy
gratificante con una variedad épica de
romances intensos
guerras civiles intrigas políticas
aventureros trotamundos y más personajes
llamados aureliano de los que te puedas
imaginar pero no es un mero drama
histórico 100 años de soledad es uno de
los ejemplos más famosos del género
literario conocido como realismo mágico
en el los hechos y poderes
sobrenaturales se describen con un tono
realista y objetivo mientras los hechos
reales de la vida y la historia humana
se revelan llenos de absurdos
fantásticos
los fenómenos surrealistas que ocurren
en el pueblo ficticio de macondo se
mezclan con los hechos que ocurren en el
país real de colombia
todo empieza con un estado mítico de
aislamiento que es gradualmente expuesto
al mundo externo y pasa por múltiples
calamidades con el pasar de los años los
personajes envejecen y mueren y vuelven
como fantasmas o re encarnados en la
siguiente generación cuando llega a la
ciudad una empresa de frutas
estadounidenses llega también un
mecánico romántico siempre rodeado de
mariposas amarillas una mujer joven
empieza a flotar sí bien la novela
evolución a través de generaciones el
tiempo pasa de forma cíclica
muchos personajes tienen nombres y
características de sus antepasados cuyos
errores ellos siempre repiten extrañas
profecías y visitas de gitanos
misteriosos dan lugar a batallas y
fusilamientos de repetidas guerras
civiles la empresa de frutas abre una
plantación cerca del pueblo y termina
masacrando miles de trabajadores en
huelga en alusión a la verdadera masacre
de las bananeras de 1928 combinado con
el realismo mágico de la novela esto
produce una percepción de la historia
como una espiral descendente de la cual
los personajes no consiguen escapar
abajo de esta magia se presenta el
modelo histórico colombiano y
latinoamericano desde la era colonial en
adelante
esta es una historia que el autor conoce
bien
garcía márquez creció en una colombia
dividida por los conflictos civiles
entre los partidos liberal y conservador
él también vivió en el mexico
autocrático e hizo la cobertura
periodística del golpe de estado
venezolano de
1958 pero tal de sus abuelos maternos
hayan sido sus mayores influencias
nicolás ricardo márquez fue un veterano
condecorado de la guerra de los mil días
cuyos relatos de la revuelta contra el
gobierno conservador colombiano
inclinaron a gabriel garcía márquez para
el lado socialista en tanto la
superstición omnipresente de doña
tranquilina iguarán cotes se tornó la
base del estilo de 100 años de soledad
la pequeña casa de los abuelos en
aracataca donde el autor pasó su
infancia fue su mayor inspiración para
macondo con 100 años de soledad gabriel
garcía márquez encontró una forma única
de capturar la singular historia de
américa latina' fue capaz de retratar la
extraña realidad de una sociedad post
colonial forzada a revivir las tragedias
del pasado
a pesar de todas las fatalidades la
novela todavía trae esperanza en el
discurso del nobel garcía márquez
retrato la larga historia
latinoamericana marcada por conflictos
civiles y grandes desigualdades
pero terminó el discurso afirmando que
era posible construir un mundo mejor
donde nadie pueda decidir por otros
hasta la forma de morir donde deberá ser
cierto el amor y sea posible la
felicidad y donde las estirpes
condenadas a cien años de soledad tengan
por fin y para siempre una segunda
oportunidad sobre la tierra
si desea conocer más historias
increíbles teorías fascinantes y hechos
interesantes suscríbase a este canal
manténgase conectado
manténgase curioso
[Música]